find the greatest common factor of these
monomials and when they say monomials
that's just a fancy word for saying a
one term expression each of these only
obviously have one term in them now to
find the greatest common factor of these
the way I think about it is I like to
break up each of these terms into their
constituent parts make them a product of
the simplest things possible for regular
numbers like ten to me that means break
them up into their prime factors and for
these variable expressions like c d
squared break it up into the product of
the most simple variable for example C
times D times D so let's do that for
each of them and see what the greatest
common factor is how wait where do these
overlap in terms of their factor and we
care about the greatest overlap so let's
do this first one 10 C D squared what is
that equal to well 10 is equal to 2
times 5 is equal to 2 times 5 you could
do a factoring tree here but these are
pretty straightforward numbers to factor
into for their prime factors so 10 is 2
times 5 see all you can do is break that
you could just write that as AC no you
can't really simplify that anymore
and D squared can be written as D times
D times D times D so I've essentially
broken 10 CD squared into this into the
product of kind of the the smallest
constituents that I could think of the
prime factors of 10 and then C and then
D now let's do five C D well 5 C D part
5 is prime so its prime factorization is
literally just 5 C you can't break that
down anymore that's just a C and then
times a D so this we really didn't do
anything to this expression right there
and then finally if 25 C to the third D
squared well 25 is 5 times 5 and then we
have times C times C times C that's what
C to the third is and then we have times
d squared times D times D now what is
the greatest common factor or what is
the greatest common overlap between
these three things well they all have a
5 let me circle them you have a 5 there
you have a 5 there you have a 5 there
they all have at least one see you have
one see there one see there and then
another see there and they all have at
least one D you have a D there you have
a D there and then you have a D there
now they don't all have a second D only
the first one and the third one have a
second D and they all don't have a
second or third C only this last one has
a second or third C so we're essentially
done the greatest common factor is 5 C D
in fact you can't have a greater number
than 5 c d be a common factor because
the largest factor of 5 CD is 5 CD so
the greatest common factor of these
three monomials or these three
expressions is 5 CD but not the largest
number of factors that overlaps with all
three of these expressions is a 5-1 C
and one D